c'est un homme en colère que nous
accueillons cette semaine à preuve par
trois jacques mézard le président du
groupe rdse au sénat bonsoir bonsoir ci
d'être avec nous le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen qui occupe une place charnière
au sénat qui cherche on l'a vu ces
derniers mois sa majorité de gauche sur
chaque texte important et vous l'allié
traditionnel du ps
eh bien on le verra vous avez bien des
reproches adressés au gouvernement
suzette bloch de l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire chaque semaine avec
dailymotion
et puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
nous rejoindrons tour à tour sur ce
plateau
d'abord je disais un homme en colère à
propos notamment de la moralisation de
la vie politique
1 est ce que vous estimez d'abord que
l'expression est fondée a été bien
trouvé par le gouvernement le chef de
l'état je condamne tout ce qui est
excessif
nous sommes dans une république comme
dans tous les pays où certaines
personnes ne respectent pas la loi ça
existe chez les élus ça existe chez les
magistrats ça existe chez les citoyens
la première chose à faire c'est
d'appliquer la loi de la république
celles qui existent avant dès qu'il ya
un problème d'essayer d'en faire voter
une nouvelle et je crois
qu'effectivement jeter l'opprobre sur
toute la classe politique surtout les
élus qui sont des centaines de milliers
dans ce pays qu'ils font pour la plus
grande majorité d'entre eux un bon
travail au service du public des
citoyens ce n'est pas raisonnable et je
crois que le gouvernement a réagi dans
l'urgence sans sérénité
à la suite de ce qu'on appelle la sphère
cahuzac
vous estimez après avoir entendu notre
nez le mot de françois hollande
relayée avec force par jean marc ayrault
que l'exécutif assure jouer
l'indignation dont je ne dis pas qu'ils
assurent jouer je pense qu'il a un peu
paniqué et que quand on réagit à chaud
on ne fait pas du bon travail quelle que
soit la sensibilité politique
j'ajoute que parler de moralisation
ça dépend qui emploie ce mot
moi j'ai été choqué par les propos du
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
sur la moralisation et notamment de
gauche sur ce thème de la moralisation
nécessaire pourquoi vient enlever ça
vous choque
ça me choque parce que je considère
comme que les deux plus grands scandales
politiques ces dernières années que ce
soit l' affaire dsk ou la sphère cahuzac
ce sont des socialistes etc avant de
donner des leçons aux autres
il est bon des purées chez soi même et
qu'en plus je ne suis pas convaincu je
sais que c'est un homme sympathique qui
a certainement des qualités je suis pas
convaincu que ce soit le mieux placé en
france pour parler de moralisation je
suis pas persuadé que ce soit forcément
un exemple par rapport à la carrière qui
la sienne c'est cette heure un parti
mais qui comme tant d'autres mais si
vous voulez quand on donne des leçons de
moralisation il faut faire attention
quand on mélange les problèmes découlant
de la sphère cahuzac avec les problèmes
de non cumul des mandats on se livre à
un amalgame qui est tout à fait
regrettez vous iriez jusqu'à reprendre
l'expression repris de justice qui a été
utilisé par kenyan jacob
je n'ai pas à me lancer là dedans je
crois que monsieur harlem désir a fait
toute sa carrière dans la vie politique
il a été conseiller économique et social
à l'âge de 29 ans qu'il a fait toute sa
carrière dans le milieu politique et je
ne crois pas que ce soit bien d'appeler
à la moralisation de la vie publique
dans ces conditions là je crois que il
est raisonnable que chacun reprenne le
bon sens que chacun considère que ceux
qui ont failli doivent être jugés par la
justice de ce pays
le code général des impôts et le code
pénal permet aujourd'hui et depuis très
longtemps de poursuivre les délinquants
en matière fiscale de manière pénale je
crois qu'il suffit de faire confiance à
la justice se payant ainsi via oui on a
des trucs gouvernement j'avais l'état
ils ont
paniquée est-ce qu'ils ont dégainé trop
vite et trop fort parce que vous dites
il ya déjà des lois qui existent sauf
qu'il y en ait une nouvelle qui veut
qu'ils se préparent et d'ailleurs il
sera présenté au conseil des ministres
la semaine prochaine elle vise notamment
à la transparence du patrimoine des élus
également et des présidents des
exécutifs à ce que vous allez vous livre
est donc de mauvaise grâce à cet
exercice sur votre patrimoine
il s'agit pas de le faire de mauvaise
grâce ou de bonne grâce si la loi est
votée
comme tout le monde j'appliquerai la loi
dirais que moi ça ne me gêne pas de
parler de mon patrimoine
j'ai exercé une activité professionnelle
pendant 38 ans avocat avocat j'ai
démissionné du barreau dès que j'ai été
élu au sénat et depuis un an j'ai déposé
cette proposition de loi au nom de bons
groupes pour clarifier un certain nombre
de choses et je crois que s'il faut
publier et bien on pu lire
mais est ce qu'il est raisonnable
aujourd'hui de jeter en pâture tous les
tous les responsables de cette manière
là alors que bien évidemment quand on a
un patrimoine si on fraude on va pas le
mettre dans la déclaration de patrimoine
à serait vous comprenez la différence
d'à proches sur ce sujet entre les
présidents des deux des deux chambres du
parlement puisque jean-pierre bel
approuve les mesures annoncées par le
gouvernement il n'est que c'est une
transparence nécessaire en revanche
claude bartolone alors lui il est vent
debout contre dénonce une démocratie
paparazzi pourquoi cette différence
c'est une affaire interne dans le parti
socialiste moi je dis simplement qu'il
est indispensable que l'on sache quelles
sont les évolutions d'un patrimoine
quand quelqu'un est élu et quand il
n'est plus élu qu'il y ait là un
contrôle très strictes que les services
fiscaux de la direction des finances
publiques et tous les pouvoirs
nécessaires pour déterminer quel est le
patrimoine pour déterminer aussi quels
sont les enrichissements voilà ce que
demandent nos concitoyens ce que nos
concitoyens demandent un c'est que des
élus ne s'enrichissent pas grâce ou à
cause de la politique et de la vie
publique
ils ne demandent pas autre chose alors
s'il faut aller dans le voyait
voyeurisme et vous savez on commence par
les élus on continuera par les
journalistes il ya va de réseaux puisque
tout est parti de lui annonce finalement
qu'il ne reviendra pas à l'assemblée
nationale est ce que vous êtes soulagé
je ne suis pas soulagé je considère que
c'est la moindre des choses
franck après ce qu'il a fait après ce
qu'il a dit il est bon pour d'abord pour
lui même parce que c'était absolument
invraisemblable d'imaginer qu'ils
pouvaient revenir à l'assemblée
nationale il est bon effectivement qu'il
qu'il démissionne
il s'agit pas de charge et sa
responsabilité elle et elle était
évidente mais bon la justice suivra son
cours et je ne doute pas qu'elle fera
son oeuvre à l'ancien ministre du budget
précise qui est infiniment peu probable
qu'il revienne un jour en politique
c'est aussi une évidence pour vous c'est
aussi des vies lancement fin on en a vu
d'autres où ça va on ne sait jamais ce
qui peut se passer
nos concitoyens sont pour la clarté pour
la transparence ils l'ont réseau ils ont
raison mais il leur est arrivé de
revoter pour des personnes qui avaient
eu des condamnations
est ce que vous estimez que le pouvoir
exécutif les disait particulièrement a
fait preuve de naïveté voire de candeur
dans la gestion du dossier cahuzac après
les premières révélations peut-être
avant je crois que c'est toujours
difficile de ne pas faire confiance et
que monsieur cahuzac avait des
compétences reconnues par tous sur tous
les bancs en matière financière il a été
président de la commission des finances
de l'assemblée
et je crois que le gouvernement a fait
confiance le pré le président de la
république a fait confiance on comment
imaginer ce qui s'est passé alors certes
on peut mettre en place des procédures
de vérification plus ferme plus solide
lorsque quelqu'un doit être nommé
ministre je pense que c'est souhaitable
et que cette expérience permettra au
gouvernement
celui ci où les suivants d'être plus
prudents parce que vous mettez en garde
je reviens au texte de loi sur la
moralisation ce que vous mettez en garde
le gouvernement contre la résistance qui
va s'organiser
surtout les rangs des assemblées sauf
peut-être chez les écologistes pour
écouter j'ai pas l'impression que
monsieur noël mamère et eu envie de
déclarer son patrimoine
bon donc il s'agit pas de mettre à part
les écologistes c'est comme partout il
ya des opinions diverses là dessus je
crois très simplement qu'il faut que le
parlement réfléchissent prennent des
décisions de sagesse c'est à dire fasse
le maximum pour que tout ce qui faillit
ce soit sanctionné fasse le maximum pour
que tous les moyens soient donnés aux
services fiscaux pour faire les
contrôles nécessaires et qu'on arrête de
ne parler que de la déclaration de
patrimoine de tel ministre de tel député
de tel sénateur et puis demain de tel
conseiller d'état pourquoi pas de telles
footballeur vous avez tout à l'heure la
possibilité d'interdire certaines
professions aux politiques pour éviter
les conflits d'intérêts alors les
journalistes mais il ya surtout un
patron de presse
un ace qui n'est effectivement
compatible d'être à la fois du du
pouvoir législatif et puis de celui
qu'on appelle encore le quatrième
pouvoir
qu'est-ce qui la veille après une
contradiction je pense évidemment à jean
michel bayet le patron de votre
mouvement ou écoutez moi je penserai
d'abord à monsieur dassault je crois
qu'il faut comparer ce qui est
comparable
mais je crois surtout qu'il ne faut pas
faire de avoir de cible sur telle ou
telle profession
moi je suis de ceux qui considèrent et
j'ai déposé une proposition de loi en ce
sens il ya plusieurs mois que quand on
exerce un mandat parlementaire
on peut pas en même temps exercer une
activité professionnelle on peut pas à
la fois nous dire sur le cumul des
mandats vous ne devez exercer qu'un
mandat est considéré qu'il est normal à
côté d'exercer une activité
professionnelle
par contre pour arriver à ça il faut
prendre des mesures pour que celui qui
n'est plus parlementaires ne se
retrouvent pas lorsqu'il a été battue ou
lorsqu'ils arrêtent dans une situation
financière catastrophique
nous avons besoin au parlement de femmes
et d'hommes de qualité il faut pas les
éloigner
on évoque la suppression de la réserve
parlementaire groupe
vous disposez de quelle somme par
exemple que blizzard c1 alors là ça n'a
pour moi ça ne pose aucun problème
nous avons dans mon groupe 164 1000
euros par sénateurs présidents et
sénateurs même somme
et c'est nous l'utilisons chacun pour
des communes moi je choisis des deux dd
uniquement des communes avec des
subventions entre 5000 et 10000 euros
mais si ça devait d'ailleurs gelé dit
dans la presse locale plusieurs fois si
on veut intégrer ça dans la dotation
d'équipement des territoires ça ne me
pose aucun problème là aussi on est un
peu dans le fantasme et dans l'anti
parlementarisme de base
aujourd'hui il y à des parlementaires
qui subventionne des associations
diverses et variées je ne donnerai pas
de nom ni de groupe je pense pas que ce
soit une bonne chose
je crois que là-dessus s'il faut
supprimer la réserve parlementaire
personnellement ça va un peu je prends
je pense que c'est vraiment epsilon par
rapport aux vrais problèmes de notre
pays aujourd'hui alors les aborder tout
de suite est vrai problème notamment le
chômage bien sûr la croissance en berne
vous allez pouvoir vous exprimer sur la
politique suivie en matière économique
sur la manière dont le navire
gouvernemental est éconduit ou tang et
puis également sur la présidence
hollande qui veut fêter bien sa première
année dans quelques jours tout cela en
répondant aux questions de suzette bloch
de l' agence france-presse
mais d'abord jérôme navier revient sur
certaines crispations qui rendent
aujourd'hui votre groupe plus
indispensable que jamais à l'exécutif
plus anciens groupes parlementaires du
sénat
héritier de la gauche démocratique
fondée en 1892
le groupe rdse des fidèles qui a une
seule ligne sa liberté quitte à se
fâcher avec les différentes majorités
qui se succèdent au sénat en particulier
sur tout ce qui touche aux liens avec
le territoire cumul des mandats
décentralisation et dernièrement réforme
du mode de scrutin local
pour eux la réponse est claire c'est non
c'est vrai que sur les modes de scrutin
l'euro perdait ce à sa position à sa
manière d'analyser les choses
il a du mal parfois à tomber dans des
solutions qui disent on courait le
risque de minorer ce que peut être un
parti plus limité en terme de candidats
ou en termes d'élus défendre le scrutin
majoritaire à tout prix pour défendre
des baronnies locales disent leurs
détracteurs influent dans les
territoires ils ont aussi trois de leurs
représentants au sein du gouvernement
une autre facette de la majorité
complémentaire des verts qui les voient
comme des alliés malgré des différences
évidentes de vécu politique ce sont
souvent des notables mais pour moi le
propos n'est pas péjoratif et évidemment
ils ont au regard de leur histoire est
aujourd'hui de ce qu'il représente une
vision probablement
plus classique effectivement de la façon
de faire la politique respecté autant
qu'ils sont craints ces faiseurs de
majorité sénatoriale regroupe des
radicaux de toutes tendances un élu ump
est même intégré en leur sein mais
depuis le départ de deux élus dont jean
marie bockel pour le groupe union
centriste
les radicaux penche plus à gauche ce que
regrette avec humour l'ancien premier
ministre jean-pierre raffarin qui devait
lui aussi composer avec quand il
gouverner globalement ils discutent et
finalement ils votent souvent avec la
gauche quand même donc ils sont un peu
moins ouverts qu'ils en ont l'air
liberté d'idées comme de vote pas de
consigne chez les radicaux
une position qui complique les calculs
de la majorité qui dépend de au sénat
reconnus pour leur savoir faire
parlementaire ils savent en tout cas se
faire respecter de tous les autres
groupes sénatoriaux il faut discuter
avec eux les entendre peut-être pas
toujours les écouter mais les entendre
voilà entendu vous avez l'assurance
écoutez pas toujours par des mots
partenaires socialistes ils feraient
bien de nous écouter vous avez
maintenant un quart d'heure pour passer
le message
bonsoir
le gouvernement a paniqué dites vous il
ressemble de plus en plus un bateau ivre
il prend l'eau tout pas s qui a pas aux
problèmes de gouvernail et il ya
manifestement un problème puisque nous
le ressentons tous depuis plusieurs mois
ceci étant je voudrais quand même dire
que sur l'économie sur l'emploi sur la
compétitivité sur le social le
gouvernement d'abord a hérité d'une
situation très difficile avec un
endettement de la france considérable
dont il a hérité avec une balance
commerciale a catastrophique et que et
que ça s'aggrave
enfin il faut dire qu'il faut du temps
pour redresser les choses et autant nous
pouvons être critique sur un certain
nombre de dossiers
nous considérons la nation comme le peu
d'honneur
dans ma famille un paquebot de
l'économie mais du paquebot de
l'exécuter de l'exécutif
jean marc ayrault qui ont obligé de
sermonner ses ministres aujourd'hui
c'est manuel valls contre dit chritiane
taubira votre camarade du prg sur
l'évasion en truand et ce kit est ce
qu'il est politiquement mort
c'est politiquement mort est ce que ça
existe la mort en politique ce que l'on
peut dire je suis assez d'accord avec
une analyse qu'a fait récemment le
sénateur gorce socialiste en disant que
le gouvernement était trop le résultat
des courants du parti socialiste et de
la parité que manger rien contre la
parité et les courants du parti
socialiste il existe ceci étant nous
avons besoin
oui la part il a parlé d'un pse la dx
est un sénateur socialiste je lui ai
envoyé un mail pour lui dire que je
trouvais que ces propos correspondait à
ce que je pensais
alors dites nous ce que vous pensez vous
avez bien crois que ce que j'ai à dire
c'est que un gouvernement mais c'est
toujours difficile doit être
représentatif du meilleur de toutes les
compétences que l'on peut trouver et que
et c'est difficile de faire un
gouvernement surtout bon que le le
système présidentiel
l'hyperprésidence qui n'a jamais cessé
sous la vème république y compris
maintenant abouti au fait que l'on fait
plus des gouvernements en fonction
depuis un certain nombre d'années des
ministres jugeaient incompétent je
trouve qu'il y a dans ce gouvernement
des ministres de grande qualité je pense
à monsieur 15 9
par exemple je pense à un marié scoffier
évidemment qui ait de sujet nous à
sylvia pinel qui est qui et prg il y a
monsieur sapin a fait un très bon
travail et dans l'autre sens vous vous
savez comme moi qu'un certain nombre de
ministres
correspondent pas forcément à ce que
l'on attend mais faire un gouvernement
où il y ait que des ministres parfait ça
je crois qu'il y a un problème inhérent
maintenant à l'évolution de la vème
république
c'est que nous avons gelé dit une
hyperprésidence que tout vient de
l'elysée même quand un président et lui
dit je vais faire différemment du
précédent on l'a vécu avec presque tous
les présidents qui se sont succédé
depuis georges pompidou et on voit bien
que le système de cette hyper présent
nous sommes le seul pays européen qui en
fait
elie tous les cinq ans une âme monarque
bon ils ont les choses un peu
brutalement mais ça ressemble à ça est
bien la vraie question est de savoir
s'il ne faut pas faire évoluer aussi ce
système qu'on l'appelle sixième
république ou que l'on appelle ça une
modification constitutionnelle forte
je crois vraiment aujourd'hui que le
parlement n'a plus suffisamment de
pouvoir qu'il est souvent méprisé par
les gouvernements successifs de droite
ou de gauche et que l'arrêt dernière
révision constitutionnelle n'a pas
amélioré les choses sur bien des points
parce que ce n'est pas parce qu'on
fabrique de la loi un qu'on a forcément
du poids va cette fois cumulés des lois
si elles ne sont pas appliquées
ça n'a guère de sens et pas ce n'est pas
une question d'hommes et une question
mais un cinquième république
oui je crois parce que jean marc ayrault
je respecte profondément le premier
ministre jean-marc ayrault qui est un un
homme honnête au sens premier du terme
et lui est ce qu'il est à la hauteur
parce que l'on fait la différence entre
ceux qui ceux qui n'ont pas le niveau
requis
vous vous mettez dans quel coin du
gouvernement de quel côté pardon je
crois que c'est c'est un homme de
qualité je crois que c'est sur l'auto
rien ministre qui l'a vraisemblablement
et celles à l'opinion que nous pouvons
avoir un problème d'autorité dans son
gouvernement et dans sa majorité et dans
sa majorité
bon qu'est ce que voulez vous on a vu
l'épisode de notre dame des landes voilà
des opposants qui sont là depuis qu'ils
ont autant qu'est ce qu'il aurait dû
faire
envoyez la force il l'a fait écouter
envoyer la force peut-être aussi et
expliquer à certains de ses partenaires
que c'est un vrai problème de fond
d'écologie du gouvernement qui
soutiennent les manifestants oui je
crois que ça il ya un soin faire qu'on
pensait que j'allais le virer
je crois que je crois que vos vies c'est
mon opinion personnelle si vous me posez
la question j'ai l'habitude d'assumer en
tout cas à les prévenir
parce qu'on peut dans une majorité
exprimé les opinions différentes
je crois que nous nous le faisons sur un
certain nombre de sujets très clairement
mais il y a au niveau de l'autorité du
gouvernement quand on est dans la
majorité
un certain nombre de choix et de
comportement est ce que vous pensez
qu'il fallait aussi gérer les ministres
rebelles nôtres qui ont ces noms qui ont
fait entendre une musique différente
économique est là on retrouve cécile
duflot d'ailleurs gouvernement et donc
c'est arnaud montebourg jean benoît
hamon qui est vrai que je injection
politique ce n'est que quand ministres
réclament une inflexion politique ça ne
me choque pas je pense qu'il doit
d'abord le faire au sein du conseil des
ministres au sein du gouvernement et
qu'ensuite c'est tout à fait de manière
noël c'est normal ils se sont exprimés à
l'extérieur je crois qu'il faut là aussi
être mesuré tout dépend de la forme qui
est utilisée si c'est une remise en
cause du fond de l'action du
gouvernement c'est difficile de la part
d'amis ni des membres éminents de
montrond plus rds jean pierre
chevènement a dit avec raison il faut
quand on est ministre
si on n'est pas content et bien on
démissionne bon il a employé une formule
célèbre
votre avis mais quand on est on arrivé
là qu'est ce qui cloche jusque là est ce
que la gauche n'était pas préparée et
mal préparée
c'est vraisemblablement eu une partie de
l'explication mais il ne faut pas
oublier non plus que nous sommes dans
une situation que l'on dit de crise mais
qui en fait est un une situation de
mutation de société considérable pas
simplement en france d'ailleurs les
problèmes que nous avons en france
il suffit de voir les pays voisins en
europe et ailleurs dans le monde pour se
rendre compte que ça passe et que ces
questions de grandes mutations de
société aujourd'hui sont prégnantes et
ont des conséquences sur la vie de tous
les peuples et sur les gouvernements et
que gouverner aujourd'hui en ces
périodes difficiles c'est beaucoup plus
difficile que lorsque tout va bien mais
est-ce que certains ministres craignent
un remaniement
didon est ce que vous vous l'appelez de
vos voeux est-ce que vous l'espérez je
crois un qu'un remaniement silva ce
n'est qu'une opinion personnelle
je crois qu'un remaniement serait utile
et là aussi il ne faut jamais réagir à
chaud je crois qu'après un an
d'expérience de gouvernementale il est
légitime de ferran un bilan et puis
peut-être de voir ce qui n'a pas bien
fonctionné aussi ce qui a fonctionné
parce qu'on a l'impression que tout va
mal ce qui n'est pas vrai il y à un
certain nombre de choses et je les dis
qu'ils vont bien est-ce qu'il va bien je
trouve que l'action du gouvernement sur
le plan économique les grandes
orientations et grandes orientations
économiques
le gouvernement a pris des mesures
courageuses scène sur la compétitivité
je pense qu'il n'est pas forcément aller
assez loin parce que le rapport gallois
qui est un excellent rapport avec 22
propositions sérieuses mérite d'être
appliquée aux de rigueur je vous savez
que veut dire la rigueur toute gestion
publique nécessite de la rigueur la
gestion par contre la rigueur ça ne
ça ne veut pas dire faire des coupes
sombres partout mais pourtant le fmi
aujourd'hui à publier à a dit que la
france était en récession
oui le haut conseil des finances
publiques monsieur migaud a dit que
vraisemblablement aussi en allait être
en récession
face à ça nous savons tous qu'on peut
pas faire vivre en pays dans une
situation d'endettement considérable
avec une croissance soit stable soit
qu'ils diminuent et que ça nécessite des
mesures difficiles
la vraie difficulté un cadeau par
lesquels vous parler des réductions pas
des réductions des dépenses et revenus
doit faire attention mais les uns pour
ils vont atteindre un nouveau record
2014 ce n'est pas au niveau de la
fiscalité qu'on peut durablement
continuer à appuyer
c'est bien évidemment au niveau des
dépenses de l'état en forme qui met
aussi
moi je gère une collectivité
je peux vous dire que je crois qu'elle
est gérée avec rigueur
vous allez pouvoir économiser encore je
crois que on peut oui on peut citer par
c'est souvent difficile parfois dans
certains cas ce n'est pas possible dans
certains secteurs mais je crois que non
seulement on peut mais on doit encore
faire des efforts la difficulté c'est
qu'il faut que les efforts ne pèse pas
sur ceux qui sont dans les situations
les plus difficiles dit que l'une des
solutions c'est enfin de simplifier le
mille-feuille territorial rien et elle
corporatisme des aînés à tous les
niveaux à toutes les strates
administratives de ce pays que rien ne
bouge
c'est vrai alors est ce que c'est vrai
c'est vrai la difficulté a été vécu par
sous la présidence de nicolas sarkozy on
a vu ce qui est arrivé au conseiller
territorial qui était quand même
une espèce d usine à gaz sur la
décentralisation et pourquoi parce que
le gouvernement n'ait pas lieu il a
consulté tous les étages les maires de
france les départements de france les
régions de france
les maires ruraux les agglomérations les
petites villes les moyennes villes
évidemment chacun et c'est légitime mais
rien ne change mais ça c'est un problème
de gouvernement il ya un moment
d'autoritaire une autorité
monsieur lézard pour revenir à la
question du remaniement est ce que vous
pensez qu'il fallait ouvrir au centre
vous verriez ans par exemple
béroud premier ministre paraît pas vous
allez peut-être un peu loin moi nous
sommes quand même de centre gauche où
nous sommes des nous avons une tradition
de tous nous avons une tradition de
tolérance et nous souhaitons qu'il y ait
un consensus non pas une union nationale
mais un consensus sur les dossiers les
plus lourds qu'il y ait une ouverture ce
moi ça ne me choque pas bon ça ne choque
pas parce que je la souhaite vous le
souhaitez oui moi je veux ça ne me
choquerait pas du tout enfin vous parlez
premier ministre c'est autre chose mais
quand on avoue que l'ouverture d'accord
jusqu'aux centristes jusqu'au mouvement
démocrate de françois bayrou voilà votre
position on a beaucoup parlé de
l'autorité du premier ministre sur son
gouvernement pas tellement finalement de
celle de françois hollande quand vous
voyez les unes des magazines on parle
est ce que ppr est à la hauteur on parle
de l'homme
faible hollande bashing chaque président
de la république vit dans les magazines
des moments difficiles nous l'avons vécu
avec le précédent président de la
république je crois que c'est excessif
et que ce qui est excessif l'on peut
dire que c'est insignifiant parce qu'il
ya un réel manque de compétence de
certains ministres or le chef de l'état
contrairement à son prédécesseur est
aussi attaqué sur sa compétence
écoutez moi je crois que le président de
la république est compétent je crois que
il est nécessaire maintenant
effectivement au niveau des
fonctionnements du gouvernement après le
choc de compétitivité nous avons le choc
de moralisation je crois qu'ils font
effectivement le champ de compétence le
choc de compétences la formule reste
arrive donc d'abord un combat majeur
monsieur mais c'est la laïcité dont on
parle beaucoup aujourd'hui avec la
fronde anti mariage gay des milieux
catholiques qui pourrait freiner dit ans
d'autres réformes par exemple sur la fin
de vie ou sur la recherche sur l'embryon
qui sont aussi de vos combats vous
l'avez montré votre engagement pour la
cité en faisant adopter une loi au début
de l'année c'était en janvier bien
françois hollande n'ont pas à nous
annonce une autre loi lui après les
derniers rebondissements de la sphère de
la crèche baby loup alexandra colinot le
19 mars dernier la cour de cassation
annule le licenciement d'une employée
voilée de la crèche baby loup
la décision choque la classe politique
la laïcité largement débattue en 2004
préoccupe à nouveau le pouvoir en
sortant quelques secondes de mes
fonctions je veux vous dire combien je
regrette la décision de la cour de
cassation aujourd'hui sur la crèche baby
loup est sûre cette mise en cause de la
laïcité
la loi doit intervenir le défenseur des
droits dominique baudis a d'ailleurs
saisi le premier sur cette nécessité
depuis le groupe ump a déposé une
proposition de loi sur la neutralité
religieuse au sein des entreprises
pourtant une loi existe déjà mais est
resté dans les tiroirs déposée par le
groupe rdse et
voter dans la douleur par le sénat en
janvier 2012 elle est finalement restée
lettre morte à l'assemblée cette loi
inscrivait déjà la neutralité religieuse
dans le règlement des crèches
bénéficiant d'une aide publique
il ya toujours des gens qui sont des
bonnes idées piennes moment donné a oui
non mais là c'est pas le moment
donc nous radicaux vont na na pas
retirer cette proposition de loi de la
niche alors qu'on nous avait demandé de
le faire
elle a été un peu rangée parce qu'on
s'est dit peut-être qu'on va laisser un
peu passé temps peut-être que c'est pas
le moment
une histoire de timing donc la laïcité
n'en reste pas moins un marqueur fort de
l'identité du groupe
du côté des religieux le discours est
bien sûr tout autre aujourd'hui
monseigneur vingt-trois s'est inquiété
de la fracture de la cohésion sociale
que provoquerait une nouvelle
législation sur la laïcité très virulent
même enseignant 23 sur un salon de
sujets de société qui me sont chers
votre réaction
pour commencer à la charge assez
violente venu aujourd'hui contre la
laïcité une charge de monseigneur
vingt-trois le cardinal s'oppose à une
nouvelle législation au motif que cela
va renforcer la stigmatisation contre
certaines religions il pense notamment
aux juifs et musulmans quelle est votre
réaction
écoutez la laïcité pour nous est quelque
chose de fondamental c'est ça fait
partie des valeurs essentielles du
radicalisme
pour nous la religion relève de la
sphère privée et nous respectons
profondément toutes les religions mais
nous considérons qu'elles doivent tout
rester dans le domaine du privé et
qu'elles n'ont pas à avoir un impact sur
les choix du gouvernement sur les choix
de la sphère publique
c'est parce que certaines de ces
propositions de loi ou le texte futur du
gouvernement peuvent stigmatiser
certaines de ces religions il ne s'agit
pas de stigmatiser
il s'agit de au contraire de respecter
la liberté de chacun la loi de 1905 a
été un progrès considérable
nous sommes de ceux qui considérons
qu'il ne faut pas toucher à la loi de
1905 sur la séparation de l'église et de
l'état
ce qui ne veut pas dire que nous menions
une action contre la religion et contre
les religions et je regrette que
monseigneur vingt-trois se soit laissé
aller à des propos qui paraissent un peu
excessif ce n'est pas la bonne manière
nous nous respectons l'expression de des
religieux des mouvements religieux
même s'il ne partage pas sur un certain
nombre de points
les propositions que nous faisons
partage absolument pas le point de vue
du gouvernement et le vôtre concernant
le projet de loi sur le mariage pour
tous monseigneur vingt-trois dit que ce
texte prépare à une société de violence
là aussi comment vous percevez cette
leçon l'église au jour est que une
éminence comme le cardinal vingt-trois
est utilisé ces propos vous savez le
mariage pour tous le pays du nouveau
pape l'argentine déjà franchi le pas un
certain nombre de pays l'ont fait ce
sont des débats de société où toutes les
opinions doivent pouvoir c'était tout à
fait contre la loi dans son pays et en
argentine ne reste pas moins que son
pays qui est quand même et qui a une
grande tradition catholique comme
l'espagne aussi la voter bon ce sont des
réformes sociétales qui aujourd'hui
mobilise beaucoup dans un sens ou dans
un autre mais je constate que sur le
terrain beaucoup de une large majorité
de nos concitoyens ne considère pas cela
comme quelque chose d'essentiel
est ce que pour autant le gouvernement
devait accélérer le calendrier sur ce
texte au risque de la radicaux risque
d'une certaine radicalisation des propos
tenus on a entendu que j'ai une part
nous promène boussens christine boutin à
la guerre civile cette semaine
quand des antilles un tome 1 de
groupuscules aujourd'hui comme le dit le
ministre on voit bien que le camp des
anti à une tendance une certaine
tendance à l'extrémisme à une
récupération de mouvement très marquée
ce qui va ou d'un autre côté le
gouvernement
en focalisant à l'origine au début les
médias sur ce dossier n'a pas forcément
fait le meilleur choix
enfin le initialement maintenant je
crois que au stade où on en est plutôt
ce sera fini mieux ce sera et quand le
canal 23 dit également que tous les
moyens ont été mis pour éviter le débat
public sur le mariage gay y compris à
gentilles dans le processus
parlementaire il dit vrai nom alors là
vraiment si un sujet sur lequel il y a
eu des bas pendant les élections à la
présidence de la république
ensuite dans les assemblées c'est bien
celui ci je trouve même que le débat a
été particulièrement long ce qui après
tout est une bonne chose mais dire qu'il
n'ya pas eu de débat ce n'est pas
raisonnable je crois qu'il n'est pas bon
dans notre société que des religions
quelqu'elle soit veuille peser à l'excès
sur des choix qui sont fondamentaux pour
la société je pense à la recherche sur
l'embryon par exemple l'embryon
effectivement il ya un texte qui est
porté par les radicaux et qui a subi
l'obstruction de l'ump de la droite à
l'assemblée nationale du coup le texte
n'est plus réinscrit à l'ordre du jour
le gouvernement pour l'instant renâclent
à l'inscrire également comment vous avez
fait je constate que là il y à une
instrumentalisation politique qui
découle du conflit sur le mariage pour
tous parce qu'au sénat nous avons fait
voter ce texte sur la recherche sur les
cellules embryonnaires à une très large
majorité de mémoire 203 contre 80 avec
des sénateurs de l'ump du centre et de
la gauche donc il n'y avait pas
recul pour ne pas fâcher encore plus les
catholiques je suis convaincu que le
gouvernement ne va pas reculer et que si
le gouvernement recule et nous nous
reprendrions ce texte dans nos espaces
réservés
car il s'agit de quoi il s'agit de
permettre à notre pays de ne pas perdre
de temps sur la recherche fondamentale
de ne pas être dépassé par ce qui se
passe dans nombre d'autres pays et je
crois que le blocage qui a eu lieu est
tout à fait détestable
pas si sûr que ça quel gouvernement ne
va pas retarder certains textes 1 il se
murmure que sur la fin de vie par
exemple là également on pourrait envoyer
les choses à plus tard pour ne pas
heurter les cathos selon moi c'est tout
à fait c'est tout à fait possible
je crois en effet que il ne faut pas
trop charger la barque des dossiers des
lois sociétal la priorité de nos
concitoyens aujourd'hui c'est l'économie
c'est l'emploi juste pour finir sur le
mariage sur les catholiques et c'est à
l'institut civitas a organisé toute la
semaine dernière des prières dans la rue
face au sénat pendant l'examen du projet
de loi ici est ce qu'il aurait fallu
interdire ces prières que ça vous a
choqué ça m'a choqué sur le plan
américain
nous connaissons sur plan je dirais de
personnel mais je crois qu'il eût été
tout à fait regrettable d'interdire cela
il faut laisser nos n'y penseront plus
dans quelques semaines et dans quelques
mois ils se sont pas les seuls à faire
des prières dans la rue jeudi avait
d'ailleurs que c'est pas forcément une
bonne chose ni pour eux ni pour les
autres jacques mézard dans tout ce
calendrier parlementaire est en vue du
prochain congrès qui est annoncé à la
fin du mois de juillet avec quatre
projets de loi de révision
constitutionnelle
le fait que le gouvernement ait plus ou
moins abandonné votre proposition de loi
sur le sur la laïcité mais également sur
la recherche sur les embryons
est-ce que du coup les radicaux de
gauche pour être un petit peu vexé
ne pas voter les révisions
constitutionnelles en congrès en juillet
prochain
nous ne prenons pas des décisions sur
des textes législatifs encore plus
constitutionnel au motif que nous
serions vexé je crois simplement
qu'aujourd'hui un congrès c'est à dire
la réunion de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat pour voter des textes à
caractère constitutionnel n'est pas
forcément justifié parce que dans ces
quatre textes il y à quoi il ya le
statut il y a le statut du chef de
l'état par rapport à des dossiers
d'ordre civil et pénal
il y à la réforme du conseil supérieur
de la magistrature
vous savez aujourd'hui on n'est pas
contre nous ne sommes pas contre ceci
étant elle ce qu'il ya une urgence
particulière à ces quatre textes je ne
pense pas je pense que le parlement a
d'autres chats à fouetter que ces quatre
textes
à l'heure actuelle mais toujours est il
si le congrès est convoquée fin juillet
à versailles
vous irez est-ce que vous voterez ces
quatre textes bien sûr que nous irons
est ce que vous voterez c4 tech et ça
c'est une décision qui sera prise par
nos parlementaires après examen de ces
quatre textes nous expliquerons avant au
gouvernement au président de la
république je l'avais d'ailleurs fait
auprès du premier ministre que vraiment
ça nous rejoue pas de réunir le congrès
que nos concitoyens attendent autre
chose
traîné des pieds mais des trois
cinquièmes je suis pas sûr que
simplement nos 18 voix fasse la
différence quand même
mais pas vexé mais vous fait désirer
quand même vous écoutez écoutez si le
gouvernement désire donnant-donnant
quand même aussi peut-être certains
textes dont on avait aussi
moi je n'ai pas l'habitude de marchander
est ce que vous n'avez vous savez jamais
été aussi fort au sénat
on parlait d'un groupe charnière tout à
l'heure avec cette majorité introuvable
puisque alain vidalis le ministre chargé
des relations avec le parlement dit lui
même que le sénat n'est pas de gauche
quant à moi ce qu'on nous dit et je
préside un groupe libre qui va de robert
hue en sera mais je dirais jamais votre
si puissante qu'elle a été trop nous
avons été beaucoup plus puissants sous
la troisième république est la quatrième
plus que nous avions la majorité gestion
plus nombreux je vous remercie
effectivement avec jean michel baylet
jean pierre chevènement robert hue et
mes collègues christian bourquin et je
pourrai tous les sites et nous avons des
parlementaires de qualité vous savez
jusque jusqu'à la fin de l'année nous
avons voté tous les pros majoritairement
pas tous puisque nous avons un ump dans
hop
nous avons voté majoritairement tous les
projets de loi du gouvernement
simplement nous avons exprimé des
opinions fortes en disant attention là
nous croyons que vous ne prenez pas la
bonne direction et nous volent exprimant
sur la réforme t pas forcément puisque
nous n'avons pas voté le texte sur la
réforme des départements des communes et
des intercommunalités nous avons voté
certains points mais pas tous parce que
nous considérons qu'il est nécessaire
que nous exprimions au gouvernement sur
certains points des différences voilà
notamment sur les scrutins locaux
effectivement le texte a été rejeté une
nouvelle fois hier soir par le sénat ça
veut dire que le sénat ne va pas peser
sur le texte final c'est l'assemblée qui
valent le dernier mot
première fois depuis des dizaines
d'années voilà on a seulement totalement
déposséder finalement exactement on
avait dit que le conseiller territorial
avait faire perdre nicolas sarkozy les
sénatoriales de 2011 est ce que vous
diriez vous aujourd'hui que le fameux
binôme pour les élections
départementales hommes femmes à stricte
parité va faire perdre les sénatoriales
à la gauche en 2014 coûté non le binôme
ne suffit pas à faire perdre par contre
je ne pense pas que ce soit un atout
pour ceux qui leur ont voté très bien
merci à tous les deux merci beaucoup
monsieur lézard de super insa la fin de
cette émission on va trouver la semaine
prochaine a très vite bonsoir
une semaine politique et parlementaire
passé au crible de l'image et du
questionnement la compétitivité
maintenant c'est un problème le coût du
travail qui n'était pas un problème
n'existait pas et maintenant un problème
la crise écologique et plus en plus
vivre eh bien on a besoin de changer les
choses et rapidement parlement hebdo
pour ne rien manquer pour te comprendre
c'est vendredi à 17h45
il s'énerve il énerve aussi parfois
quand il est hors norme dans le paysage
politique avec ses colères sa gouaille
et ses coups de gueule y compris contre
son camp alors à quel jeu joue comme
même dit que penser de ces différentes
facettes et quel bilan tire t'il à
l'heure où il annonce sa retraite
d'europe écologie cette semaine des as
bio en tout bien tout honneur
déshabillons-les samedi à 23h45 sur
public sénat
quand on pose la question aux français
par rapport à leurs leurs origines
idéologiques et politiques les deux
tiers des français se disent de droite
ou de gauche
comme leurs parents et quand les parents
ne sont ni de droite ni de gauche is ils
disent également qu'ils sont ni de
droite ni de droite et de gauche c'est
vrai que dans 60 % ça c'est vrai que la
transmission du politique dans la
famille comme d'ailleurs la transmission
aussi des choix religieux la politique
et la religion constitue une sorte de
toujours de noyau dur dans dans la
transmission dans la transmission
familiale et du coup c'est vrai que ces
choix ont tendance à se transmettent
alors ça ce n'est pas pour autant que ce
sont des choix à l'identique c'est à
dire que on on a les mêmes quand les
mêmes camps idéologiques on partage les
mêmes valeurs les mêmes choix ça ne se
traduit pas forcément dans les mêmes
votes
on peut être de gauche comme ses parents
mais voter différemment à l'intérieur du
camp de la gauche
même chose pour la droite moi j'étais
d'une époque où mais n'est pas les
enfants aux conversations politiques
mais voilà il y avait un milieu mon père
ouvrier milieu ouvrier alors un chai
atypique parce qu'ils étaient à la fois
socialiste et cégétiste qui n'était pas
dans les années 60 au temps de guy
mollet exactement la vulgate de l'époque
dans ces mules
mais c'est vrai que il espère première
était aussi à gauche où elle était moins
politisés ma mère c'est mon père qui
était politisé ma mère était comme
souvent dans ces époques la catholique
pratiquante moins intéressé par par la
vie politique elle voté comme votre père
mais elle votait comme mon père oui
adams a sans aucun doute à l'époque
le chef de famille déterminer quand même
un peu un peu le vote michel winock ce
genre d'histoire parlez nous des
événements historiques qui ont provoqué
de vraiment des vrais dispute dans les
familles oui parce qu'effectivement la
politique devient conflictuel
à certains moments pas tout le temps et
il y à des événements bon nous
connaissons tous la célèbre caricature
de caran d'ache né ce moment de l'
affaire dreyfus on voit une famille
rassemblée devant une table et on dit il
n'en parlerons pas et la caricature d'à
côté la table est dévasté les gens sont
que se sont bagarrés les y en a qu une
soupière sous la halle sur la tête
la légende ils en ont parlé
bon alors ça nous connaissons cette
caricature elle réagi c'est la fin
dreyfus c'est à dire que c'est un moment
de tension extrême où effectivement dans
les familles
il peut y avoir de la bagarre vous avez
évidemment la guerre d'algérie pendant
la guerre d'algérie il y a eu assurément
des conflits dans les familles
et puis 68 68 vous rendez compte 168 bon
je sais bien qu'il ya beaucoup de
parents qui ont été très bienveillant
avec les enfants qui avaient sur les
barricades
nous l'avons vu au quartier latin
notamment m'enfin quand même il y en a
beaucoup qui était
ulcéré par le fait que leurs enfants
leur échapper complètement dans les
familles les conflits ils sont moins
violents qu'ils ne l'étaient il ya
encore quoi 10 20 ans s'il ya des
conflits dans les familles les conflits
politiques conflit politique alors c'est
à dire que
ce qui ce qui se passait auparavant
c'est que certains jeunes chez les
adolescents donc la manière de s'opposer
une des manières de s'opposer était de
prendre de choisir une opinion politique
différente de celle de ses différentes
de celles de ses parents à ça on le on
le voit beaucoup moins
moi je crois que ce à quoi les enfants
sont extrêmement sensibles en famille
quand quand ils entendent leurs parents
par les politiques
alors maintenant c'est plus journal
c'est la télévision c'est à dire on
regarde le journal télévisé est dans les
bons qu'à ans le commente dans les
libyens dans les banques et dans les
bonbons un peu voilà et ce à quoi les
enfants sont très sensibles c'est à la
question de la justice et de la justice
c'est à dire que les parents qui exprime
une certaine façon d'être et et des
opinions et qui dans leurs dents dans la
vie ne sont pas comme ils disent ça ça
choque énormément les enfants et ça les
pousse à ne pas adopter les opinions
politiques de leurs parents ça dit il
voit l'hypocrisie on est toujours ancré
en a toujours un ancrage mme après
l'intérieur de cet ancrage qui fixe un
peu le cas on peut évoluer
il ya des glissements on pense pas
exactement la même chose que ses parents
ses grands-parents
les choses se sont ce sont les places et
on est moins dans le cadre que j'évoque
et heures c'est à dire la croyance des
grandes idéologies et on va dire que les
votes peuvent elles peuvent être très
différents vous avez aujourd'hui des
gens qui votent au niveau national de
telle ou telle manière
c'est plus vrai au niveau local et sur
les scrutins alors pour les mairies
c'est particulièrement vrai mais même
pour les scrutins intermédiaires c'est
un peu en fonction du projet du candidat
et les choses se déplacent de manière
beaucoup plus importante ce qui se passe
surtout aujourd'hui c'est l'abstention
c'est à dire c'est c'est le fait que le
comportement électorat et le rapport au
vote des citoyens profondément changé et
que donc il est difficile de parler de
transmission du vote de reproduction du
vote dès l'instant où s'abstenir
maintenant
est un comportement qui tient pas un
comportement majoritaire seule
l'élection présidentielle échappe à la
diffusion de l'abstention puisque vous
avez vu que quelques semaines plus tard
c'est 40% des français qui battant tous
les records